La nuit prochaine, à 2 heures du matin, il sera 3 heures.
Ce 29 mars ne durera que 23 heures au lieu de 24.
Une heure de confinement en moins
c'est toujours bon à prendre !
Mais pourquoi les jours sont-ils découper en 24 heures?
Cette division remonte aux babyloniens.
Une civilisation qui s'est épanouie
2000 ans avant Jésus-Christ au Moyen-Orient.
Les babyloniens comptaient sur quatre doigts
avec le pouce et comme nous avons trois phalanges
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12 x 2 : ça fait 24
12 c'est très pratique, on peut le diviser
par 2, par 3, par 4, par 6,
alors que 10, seulement par 2 et par 5.
Les babyloniens avaient aussi observé que l'année
dure grosso modo 360 jours : un multiple de 12.
Ils ont donc divisé l'année en 12 mois,
l'heure en 60 minutes, la minute en 60 secondes.
1 minute : c'est la durée d'une "capsule de déconfiné".
Allez à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné" :
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain !